yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I'm
sorry I'm a bit late like three to four
minutes but yeah it was a bit tricky to
install that green screen especially if
you are completely unable to do anything
with your hands besides for Mouse work
okay so let's have some fun with some
with some blitz chess hope you're all
all right had a good monday yeah in
Europe it's already late in the day but
not so much in the US let's get going
with some games going to play some five
minute on the ICC I hope all is alright
with the broadcast some info about that
is as always welcome yeah I'm going for
my name's oh here in the first game
don't see any any message in the in the
set the chap that I'm actually life as
usual here it's nice to hear that you
actually see me okay thanks for telling
me yeah I names Oh with III here it was
a bit hectic here so I'm glad everything
works I'm just posing to to the Samish
oh they retreat to be seven that doesn't
happen that often but it's not so bad
okay I'm taking the center hmm kind of
passive the setup but still rather solid
this black wants to play five I guess
okay I just play we should be too
this looks like some kind of old Indian
and billion temp you down yeah let's
just castle do I prepare before hmm yeah
I guess I do well with rope you wanna
preparing before yeah I am pushing
before someone this is a frequent photo
of my channel yeah thanks for for
watching yeah and a good idea someone
says here jersey new jersey new and
probably not pronouncing that right says
he registered on twitch to be able to to
talk on here on in the stream yeah this
is a good idea actually I'm to register
on Twitch you have this chat feature
which is very nice so we can communicate
with with other viewers and also with me
okay a black is setting up to push f5 I
don't really mind that so much i think i
can take and play Bishop d3 let's do
that
and some of the switch Chet is nice yeah
well nice I think I think it's actually
a nice to be able to chat I think that
sometimes the kind of communication is
it is questionable here with I no choice
of words and spammers and whatnot but in
general I think it's nice that you have
the the chatting opportunity okay I'm
trying to place a knight on e4 here you
will probably play Knight f6 no home so
do I just play 94 here or not I can also
try Queen g-form for a queen trade he
has g6 however difficult or just 94 I
don't know I go clean g4 it's an
interesting idea maybe it takes which i
think is a mistake on g4 yeah this is a
mistake i believe i get a pawn to g5 i
gets them to gphone okay I'm of
protecting you form someone says and by
camouflaging my reading um yeah I think
you're right this looks kind of weird
this is better yeah I'm sorry for that
as I said the the prep time for that
chat for that broadcast was somewhat was
somewhat brief someone says greetings
from beau home yeah greetings back to
boo home someone someone says will I do
more live streams on my own channel yes
i will probably tomorrow actually it
will be the next one but i'm not
entirely sure i have to have to organize
a couple of things yeah why this a bit
better here but winning is a different
matter especially my for night is nice
and behind on time this is kind of a the
usual story how do i really do things
rookie one is a move yeah let's do
worked you one trying to pressurize the
six
okay it just goes back I can take b5 and
this is sixth and play be five it's not
it's not ideal but not so bad let's do
this and try to fight for the d5 square
and yes we we had this this subject of
this background everybody prefers the
natural background yes I know I CCL
wanted me to do that now he gives me a
d5 square it's nice so b6 Wow have you
ever seen worse minor pieces probably
yes but not so often so what now I need
to promote the beep on how to do that if
I go b7 he will approach with the King
problem you cannot do much else b7
Bishop d to Bishop f5 this kind of thing
should should be okay you really cannot
move any of his pieces it's kind of
remarkable this yeah but I have still at
Bishop a 5 yeah I can tell I know I
cannot take i mean i can but does it win
I don't see a win here should a one look
be a truck a 8mm i'm down to 26 seconds
in terms
16 seconds yeah that's bad I it was such
a winning position and I couldn't finish
this off amazing amazing yeah when I
played be seven iron you that it could
be tricky yeah if you have some twitch
problems just refresh the browser that's
the only way to do it yeah this was
remarkable I mean how did I screw that
one up let me check I did not want to do
a big analysis I just want to check this
briefly because black was so totally
paralyzed that hmm sure rabbit b6 that
should win right i mean black cannot
move anything king of seven huh should
be two king bishop is Sir of course I
can take the six yeah I saw that but I
knew that I would lose on time then you
cannot I mean you have to think about
this I saw this move of course but I
lose on time that rook endgame um okay
I'm going for a new game someone says I
should do a stream to recommend chess
books yep I know that's an interesting
interesting idea I'm yeah I'm thinking
about doing that I would definitely
definitely need to announce this and i
also think of doing a stream about about
yea general chest questions like what
like opening ideas or whatever to
discuss that I'm thinking about doing
this on my own channel or also here on
now on the ICC as a question ever ever
played a game of chance other than poker
mmm yeah what I definitely have played
backgammon at some point but not in any
way that I could call it serious I mean
I even forgot the rules I couldn't play
this game now but I did this once I mean
not once i played this game more than
once backgammon but it's really on no
decent level or any level at all h3 is a
bit uncommon here but i thought it could
be interesting just preventing bishop
geforce going before I ecos d4 then hmm
ok maybe Queen d2 then g5 bishop age 3
as an option
but d 4 is kind of annoying here okay I
cannot play I cannot play call of duty
no I mean I have played this game on my
playstation but not here on the stream
so what am i doing now maybe i will be
to is hanging huh what about bishops II
to Queen d3 let's try that someone says
he finds the everyman books of varying
quality and Bob well I have produced
this my book here on the names are bogo
for everyone and in general I have to
agree here there are there are good
books and not so good books and I think
this is probably not something exclusive
to everyone I think that many publishers
they have a varying level of quality for
example if you take someone like new in
chess they have produced some great
books and also some books that well I
kind of yeah mediocre let's let's let's
call it like that um so he's going for
deform oh yeah not not great here this
position especially my queen there let's
go back
queen is 6mm what is he doing wants to
go d4 and then I don't know what he
wants to do actually let's double yeah
someone says quality chairs is always
high quality yeah that's that's probably
true they have they have the odds not so
great book but it's still pretty good
they are pretty his their name is pretty
much justified I will do more bullet
tournaments yes anh Li chess or wherever
they have bullet tournaments someone
says they're stuck at 1500 what should
what should you do well besides the very
egoistic recommendation of hiring me as
a coach you can do many things on on
that level to to improve but it depends
a little bit on your skill set something
very useful would be definitely to work
on your tactics ya doing regularly
tactics exercises is a useful thing
actually for everybody
yeah I'm activating my pieces it's
pretty draw a ship I actually offered a
draw I I didn't I didn't really see that
now we agreed and I was pretty boring I
didn't get anything out of all that
opening yeah someone asked why you
shouldn't ask about leeches on an ICC
stream yet internet chess club and
leeches are competitors so it's somewhat
clear that this shouldn't be an
advertising platform for another server
someone asked what about Svidler am i
impressed with his play um yes really
yes I think a very good job um
especially considering i mean it sounds
a little bit weird but what am I doing
here I'm black right let's not play you
five this is this is really not good c5
um the I'm especially impressed with
this play considering that means realize
it's about my age is from 1976 i believe
so two years younger than when I am and
this this kind of event is super super
stressful yeah i mean just yeah think
about this all the tires now it just
it's such a format for young people that
someone in the late 30s it's not exactly
yeah the number one natural candidate to
to do well in this and he is now
qualified for the candidates for sure
and has chances to win it for a second
time yeah for a second time really great
someone else do i do private lessons
through the internet yes I do that's my
main job nowadays yeah the main job in
this game he is to get the c-4 porn back
yeah I want this bloody pawn on c4 and
then have a nice position let's see me i
think i'm going to trade this and the
semi sloth would I recommend 5e3 or
Bishop g5 that depends a lot on how much
time you have available if you have lots
of time available and like to study
sharp and complicated lines you can play
Bishop g5 if this is not the case i
would recommend to play III it's just a
more practical choice okay I'm taking
there is going to eat six huh that's not
good how do online chess lessons work
that's pretty pretty young comparable to
chess lessons on a real bored you meet
on a known on the cert on a server of
choice very often it is the ICC and then
you do the communication via Skype this
is usually working nicely unless skype
is having a global breakdown like last
Monday um yeah if you are interested in
learning about chess lessons just drop
me an email it's um or you can also
message me on my youtube channel it's um
my first name my second name and then I
gmail.com it should be possible to to
find me what about this here um I'm
getting that a for porn but he's getting
some kind of activity going i just hope
i'm not getting crushed okay so now i
will take a four and then try to
to try to win with the a pawn yes villa
in the world cup that's really cool i he
had a great event and I think swig leah
is actually one of the underestimated
players somehow piece he won the Russian
championship seven times which is really
unbelievable and the other thing I don't
really understand is what is going on in
this position if I go up he aids nike go
look at seven I wanted to wanted to give
up my deaf if i go here and there he
goes 97 and i go King f7 am i mated I
don't see it page form okay okay I
pushed the airport oh I overlooked
before his hanging ah stupid stupid
stupid stupid I just blundered before
him but I have a weight i have to be
eight on 84 maybe hmm interesting yes
villas fellow qualified now for the
candidates tournament in 2016
you can meet on other chest service for
four lessons that's not really a really
an issue and so what now okay forward I
need to push this night away I think I
can take him yeah i saw that idea before
i will promote the airport yeah it was a
nice end yeah the sound of clapping on
my head that's a that's a an advantage
of of the board look you can make many
nice sounds sweet let Carlton for the
World Championships error sweet let
certainly would certainly be outside if
it would qualify but yeah kayaking or a
yarn officer I one of the other one of
the two will be the other qualifier for
the candidates okay I'm playing playing
lie O'Neill or something here from
Mexico right yep so
yeah the Slovaks change and that's not
exactly the most inspiring lines but
they have a great score that never lost
with it in tournament play so why not no
I shape but if I don't shave I only have
very little hair left which I thought
wasn't really having much point so
y square 3 Smith Lascaux against Karns
is not zero seven hits with a definitely
one again he won that final round game
in the 2013 candidates this in the super
dramatic final round so he definitely
has not lost all games and what is
happening here b5 is not on this is
possible though yeah so i can go d 45 is
this actually good or not hmm b5
interesting position here is he going be
five maybe I don't see a tactic working
here he's sick smooth but take f6 is
this a move I don't know
now let's let's develop swidler will win
in the press conference wisconsin and
this is probably true yeah so what is
this i was thinking i can grab that on
g6 but it's not that great actually like
a certain defining someone says no mods
are on yeah yeah we don't need any mods
here right we have civilized people or
not so what is this we have a position
here with wow that's very very stodgy
but I'll take I'll take why not I
haven't canceled yet this is this is a
bit this is some supporting the idea of
trading
yeah usually there is a mod from the icc
i'm not i don't have the moderator
rights i believe yeah this position okay
is this equal am a slightly better am i
worse I don't know actually I know that
my bishop there is not that grade on g5
but I don't want to move it right there
I'd like to get the night to d2 maybe
not sure that was a great idea but
anyway b5 I high once to play Knight to
c4 hmm it's definitely definitely an
option
it's very dry ship so a draw each
position night c4 I play be three
yeah I go be three but not so happy
about that Bishop a3 is kind of annoying
well it's still a very equal ish
position but what can you do any idea
say with the bishop air route d1 rook
hd1 Bishop II one Bishop f5 this
question what do you say about feeder
recommended book list is there one what
does feel doing they now do a list of
recommended books don't they have other
things to do like yeah installing Ethics
Commission which is the weirdest
oxymoron ever for freedom someone says
have I got any tournaments coming up no
not with me playing the next thing that
I'm going to visit is interesting I'm
going to visit the world blitz and rapid
championships looking forward to that in
Berlin I figured having them in Berlin I
should definitely yeah pay a visit
especially taking into account that I
haven't been to Berlin for ages yeah
again very dry
um yeah well I'm not playing any
tournaments myself in the near future
simply a guy that it didn't didn't fit
didn't fit schedule
then i should say you should organize a
meet up with channel viewers um yeah I
don't know how would that work I in
Berlin I don't know if there are many
channel viewers in Berlin I have no idea
my night there on d to you that's really
not a great piece wow really not much
going on here I'm thinking can I do
something here probably not him that
night here can never go anywhere fatigue
I mean if I tickets probably a draw ok
I'm going to offer me draw I'm sorry
it's kind of kind of boring here why as
Berlin so much fun and of its much fun
it's just that um I haven't been to
Berlin for almost 20 years which is
really really a long time and Dwight's
it's joe and his capital with some sites
i haven't even seen them up close some
them the reorganized um german
parliament and things like that so I
again I wasn't very exciting maybe this
time let's go ok let's go e5 hmm the
good old scotch hmm he this guy is this
kind of assists no it's a new account of
my way or something no always got
millions of games night at 5pm yeah ok
and request is for the cheek or in
willow pass yeah my wood favorite down
yeah I would have played it probably but
I got the Scotch game sprung on me Queen
d2 is a good move now that has been
played a couple of times against me by
by my way or an interesting move let's
say and I have again forgotten what's
good against that I think no g4 still
but still my way played that against me
a couple of times and what is the point
of trying to induce c3 the point is that
there is no Knight coming to see three
anymore in many variations this
this is quite important what what is
this yeah White has no development at
all and they can play before you're not
serious about that right okay this
requires punishment Bishop g4 is going
to indy to that's not going to work
Bishop f2 King takes 90 for King g1 this
is just about holding it looks like it
looks crazy
no isn't night h5 now strong night age
five it's going to check but I don't I
don't see it I'm sorry let's play this
let's check on age 6 alright sick that's
six stuff ok h6
no I think you know what he reside he
reside he resigned yeah and I think with
good reason I don't see how a defense
against night XD 3 I don't have sound on
so you don't see that I have a
challenger that screams close that ok
next one Istani I am I am who is that
guy I think I played in recently Alex
Istani Lopez ok yeah be four minor three
that wasn't the best possible
combination of moves probably so night
BTW to we added scottie 6 yep there's a
common camp that night h5 was a very bad
pinning situation I wonder ever had this
against the same player only recently
yeah I will finish by e5 repertoire you
to be I definitely the I did the Evans
gambit and the next one would be about
the Italian old main lines we see 3 and
T 4 it's already prepared but I have to
produce it and check some minor things
if I've now hmm it's an uncommon moment
to do that
I don't want to grab the pole that's not
a good idea I wonder justifiable now I
cannot mean e5 and this question have i
ever tried the play Magnus app yes I did
I actually I know that song it sounds
wacky I I I am tried that and I have
played Magnus there in the very various
ages and I actually made a video um
playing playing on my iPad was it was
rather complicated that set up it was
actually fun and then I deleted the
video accidentally it was a was a bit of
a shame I have beaten I think I won
against up to age 12 12 and 13 and 14 I
I got stuck I'm not quite sure something
like that there's a question were you
impressed by vayas play in the World Cup
um yeah yeah I think he's remarkably
remarkably resilient for his age I mean
age 16 and he's fantastic nerves and
very very difficult to beat in those
rapid time control events I think
actually that in terms of yeah I mean
strategic understanding yeah he's really
not yet on a super top level um but from
a technical point of view and and
everything that the pure sporting
performance was very good no but you
could see when you are when you are when
you saw that match um against Peter
Svidler that's villa was still having a
superior general
understanding of the game where you
could really even see that g6 I don't
want to play g6 in this position hmm hmm
and four would come anywhere hmm not
good very incubated I'm good f4 it's not
so easy to play I mean have Queen III
stuff which is six is a very
uncomfortable move I really need to
trade heavy pieces here then I'm kind of
okay there's a question why no faith
scam in those longer youtube videos and
there is a there is a reason for that um
I'm usually a no using the dash of
software a different software to that
one here and in dascha the the the setup
of the screen is um is some is in a way
that I feel um I'm I don't have a good
place to put the camera on or yeah I
don't have a good placement for the
camera I think um so I rarely rarely use
that 97 there's a question what do I
save on the cameras charges against
camuto on November I don't really know
what that is it's nakamura playing
Komodo maybe you can can give me some
more information I didn't I didn't I
didn't really learn about that I don't
know what that is she playing a match I
mean okay so I cannot take on f4
unfortunately probably the bishop back
somehow
yeah maybe g5 I know it looks bad
Nakamura will play Komodo in Prague with
odds Wow in Prague why exactly in Prague
okay anyway yeah you need some odds
probably the engine is nowadays really
too strong for regular competition
interesting move Bishop them
hmm
Oh probably out of moves here yeah and
probably probably just just lost her
oh yeah well maybe I can go like rook f6
okay okay f6 g6 something like that
right probably it's lost anyway I don't
know games with F porn ops and exchange
odds okay funny i have no idea with the
odds if this is helping a lot no Kamal
is not developed by people from the
Czech Republic I think it's from
Americans one of them is Larry Kaufman
the Grandmaster also wrote a couple of
books yeah it's so I mean I'm lost here
but I'm still kind of hanging in there
c5 I probably has a couple of ways to to
win here stake here yeah my bishop he is
hanging him this is the issue one of the
issues
yeah it's just lost nothing that I can
do here really
none of my queen Akkad was lost he woke
lady very nicely there I always had a
bad position somehow okay as a question
other opening books for wide according
to Anand good as reference work and yeah
they're not bad at all but they are a
couple of years old and they are very
heavy on on on lines I mean they provide
very little in terms of why this move is
chosen or whatever it's it's a very very
variation heavy series of books if you
wanted before a book um II for opening
book um I think something to to check
out is the upcoming quality chest
publication by Grand Master John Shaw
it's doing a 212 volume book on one year
for which is maybe easier to handle than
the Arnold books um I'm not saying that
they're bad it's just that they have
their the issues that same um what about
this here h3 I guess that's the question
what am i doing when I don't play chess
and not much not much really I'm
complete complete chestnut so he's
attacking be to write would be one
really wants a bit lame anyway let's do
it
yeah we have some kind of benoni benoni
type of position I could have played
even before in this what is what is
black doing here I don't get it Bishop
he is something bad happening to me or
not I don't quite know yeah chess is my
only job now yes I quit last year on my
office job and nowadays focus on chest
teaching how do I do this the screen is
so offside I just need to a check yet
somehow with 92 or something Bishop c2
is taking see foreheads that's no good
to see one to play be five maybe I can
do this maybe for Bishop c2 yes yes I
had a had a regular kind of job I worked
in a bank for 17 years in controlling so
I was mostly counting the money the bank
spend on i.t if you want counting doing
reporting and yeah trying to help the
management to decide on things usually
unsuccessfully they simply wouldn't do
what I want them to do I don't know ok
now I'm playing before no one is
stopping me from there ok so b5 for more
space I liked space
okay no I'm switching to the Kings side
what is a good book to start with a
Spanish hmm not so easy really hey I
could wrap it to a book I mean for you
me for white probably right you asked
about the island series hmm now not that
I'm aware of something that is kind of
usable they have been things like
Spanish books that was won by Andrew
greed I think but it was about some
sideline the what's the name them ver al
variation with Queenie to of oral I
don't know how it is pronounced I'm
sorry yeah while talking about the
Spanish opening mr. nefertum here is
kind of asking himself how to prevent
Queen g7 mate and this wouldn't lead to
anything it's just made next move it was
a pretty bad position that he had moving
his Queen a bit too often the viral
attack yes'm this is the line that is
disgusting n do greets book on the
spanish i really don't know anything
great recently on the on the rim for
white I'm not sure what John Shaw is
doing I mean that's probably something
by him by am come on by mr. Neji coming
out he's probably will do the spanish
opening d phi of him but i don't know i
don't know when or what exactly he will
do Neji i mean in the GM repertoire
series
if or hear what I don't really know
what's what kind of line is that you
have no idea and the question do I play
blindfold chess no I never do that not
because I think it's particularly bad or
anything has just never been a focus
9393 cannot be bad which match and
top-level Chad's would be the most
interesting at the moment um um yeah i
think carlton koala i guess it's the
most interesting one i started with
chess age 13 i guess really late and i
joined a club with 14 of 15 in this kind
of aged a bit late but it shows that
there's still hope to get to somewhat
decent level yeah the grandmaster
repertoire serious oh it's a bit
difficult it's really something
sometimes close to unusable by my normal
people and I'm including myself I mean
I'm not really saying that that that I'm
the the target group for those books
sometimes I feel oh it's just far too
much so let's have a look there I don't
believe this one bit what black is doing
here but how how to play 95 you will
take and then I'm okay but I'm not
better not much at least write a 4mm
that doesn't lead to much maybe this
have take with the pawn
Thomas says Grisha vs cards would be
cool with one more hour for Greece shock
that's maybe true here but Greece shop
without his time travel would wouldn't
really be greased shock right so um here
what am I doing here is going to target
this pawn I think I'm just going to
cover it the question I started playing
did a study all the time I just played
casually and then started to study later
yeah well I think everybody kind of
starts in a casual way and then gets
more serious about it um we were just
playing a like it's and and there was
some group at our school and yeah and
then I wanted to get better so it all
started from there you know my bishops
get really strong yeah gushue gets into
time travel because he needs cigarette
breaks yeah this is probably one one
point of it but it's also i think is
probably some kind of action junkie who
just needs it um but he really does
smoke during the games um take takes a
cigarette breaks I really could with
witness that firsthand when I played the
European club cab last year in Spain he
was out all the time smoking not all the
time but right through quite frequently
I also used to go there I mean I'm not
smoking anymore but I'd like to leave
the hall and and walk some walk a little
bit and you had the few smokers out
there smoking all the time it's really
kind of obvious that smoking has become
something rare in
top level chess I mean there were only
really a few people there smoking yeah
my bishops are really strong what about
that b7 porn mr. Ketchum yeah ok I'm
going rook g1 and rook c1 and Roxy 7i
guess ok I didn't think about this move
that much can I castle or is that bad
Castle Bishop takes rook e1 king is
seven huh yeah someone says that Bishop
does not know where he spends the time
yeah it's it's it's quite often the case
with the notorious time travel players
that they don't really know what they
think about yeah this this is not the
ideal result really from my great
position at least I'm a minute up on the
clock
yeah this how do I play here like we'll
see one is going to be eight probably
centralized and play be three he might
have Bishop c5
yeah that's one remark in the chat that
is very true someone says that they that
they waste time during a game of chess
thinking about earlier earlier decisions
that they regret yeah and this is a
really common mistake that leads to time
travel very often that you kind of think
ah why didn't I do this in that and this
is a really total waste of time I
understand the idea you kind of think
but this is this is really bad you're
only should focus on the position at
hand just the one that you have in front
of you and not what happened before what
you could have done differently or
things like that this is really really
something to do okay now i can take on d
7 and then March up there it's a very
simplistic way of playing why it cannot
really be go time now let's just play
normals if I can I do this yeah i think
i can now 95 i can check with the rook
so maybe here trying to trade rocks
okay I'm going up with my king there's a
question if you should play shorter
games or longer games and trying to
improve I think they're this is a
interesting an interesting discussion
which is kind of debated among chest
coaches mostly about should you play
blitz or not I think that blitz is
totally fine to play as long as you
don't overdo it it's um it's a good it's
a good way playing blitz to get games in
and and and learn about patterns opening
patterns things like that so it it makes
perfect sense to play some blitz what am
I doing here is he really coming to a 5
hmm I'm splayed that huh champ I really
miss played that not winning this game
is kind of heartbreaking
and wonder if i can try something
probably not huh it's really just a draw
okay let's stop him can I stop the porn
just about here and I'm covering all
those okay it's a wrong okay interesting
game I guess so yeah playing too much
too much blitzes too much play too much
grids too much nah that was a weird
sentence um you can play some blitz but
shouldn't overdo it if you want
something in between something like
between let's say 15 to 25 minutes and
an increment 5 seconds 10 seconds is
good someone mentioned 1510 as a good
time control yes 1510 is not bad there's
a question do I agree was John with all
of you that the main difference between
players in the 1800 to 2000 range and
those higher rate it is primarily in
regard to positional chance at endgame
ability um I think there are a couple of
things definitely um positional things
are really important if you compare the
two thousand player with let's say a
feeder masks or something but in general
the feed master or master player or even
higher is usually better in all all
aspects of the game not just in one but
it happens that people like on 2000 for
example 2000 is a weird rating range
there are of rating
area if you want it like that there are
a couple of people around 2000 who are
really strong technically but cannot
really do anything in regards to to
strategic chess so these are very
they're very dangerous players but they
have problems with them with long-term
planning and things like that okay I'm
playing kenstar this is actually not an
IM that's a grand master Kenny Sullivan
he got his GM title think last last year
were winning the African continental
championships and it's quite funny he's
playing my liner the line that I play
against the Kings Indian the McAuliffe
hmm i'm not quite sure what i did hear
that was any good or not Queen a5 is got
night see form
yeah chess is weird just as we had the
skill sets are completely different for
four people that's good do you agree
that 1800 players should mainly do
tactics hmm no not really it should be a
regular part of off of training but not
sure if it's a question of mainly i
think i can do many things that let make
some sense ah that's an interesting way
to play
if I go F form he has aged six later
very very weird stuff and that's the
question any advice how to study
openings and ratings / 2100 mainly books
? um no I think I mean okay there are
good books of course that you can use
but if you are really about 2100 what
you should do is mostly is getting a
database software that you have probably
anyway but you need a normal database
software like like chessbase get a good
big database and then compile your own
opening files so you should basically um
third search through the database and
put together what you like you have to
go to HHS is kind of um kind of wrong um
but what can you do yeah you have to
basically compile your own opening files
and this is the way to do it not copy
what other people think but try to
develop your own theory basically and
this will really have a lot if you are
really above 2100 you are good enough to
do that yeah I wonder if he can go d 6
or something like that for a check on c4
he covered that yeah so I'm at least on
time to do this but now he has got night
c4 which is really bothering me quite a
bit you know
d 4 is a huge issue from decidi for
someone someone wrote d4 and the chat no
the bishop 188 it's a huge issue what a
bad piece yeah this is understandable he
wants to trade that
the only thing my position has in its
favors when that's probably not so
relevant I'm I'm a bit better developed
at the moment so yeah there's a slight
miss coordination and whites visas so
yeah I have three quite clearly I'm not
sure that this was good that you allowed
this now I'm getting active really
active 93 queen bee to now you don't
need to play 1 d4 to improve your
strategic play now you can play if I'm
being a strategic show the main issue
with e for in terms of getting a
strategic position as a Sicilian and
there you can easily go for Bishop b5
lines which are there they are probably
not even worse than regular lines yeah
why does going for cross window mode I
understand ready um my bishop still
buried them what now mmm Queen B 5 or
group b 5 rupee five this is check there
and so far this is actually a draw so
let's take that the Queen and hope that
I'm I'm okay here it's not easy because
back Bishop my bishop is just so
amazingly bad
and what to do against the Syrian with
e6 because you cannot go Bishop to b5
yeah that's a good question I usually
recommend to play 333 or 3g three both
are pretty strategic and not so
difficult to learn I need the d7 porn
definitely get my bishop 188 ah what a
great piece let's trade one rook look to
see a time
yeah this is really it's not great yeah
that Bishop here okay I'm giving that
back okay I'm giving the piece back I'm
tired of this piece there are in the
corner
no my age porn is dangerous maybe I
should have gone to gauge seven actually
okay that's not bad I'll wait wait we
need not so quick let's take this this
should really promote the porn yeah the
druid Bishop one a jade a video that I
released today on my channel also had
that it's pretty terrible
nah come on it's never going to be quick
enough i am i am i doing something
stupid here no don't don't tell me that
yeah so i stopped the pawns so at the
end of the session here i'm winning like
a couple of couple of points maybe like
two or so and yeah the bishop wasn't
entombed peace yeah someone asks am i a
fan of Jeremy Silman um I cannot really
tell because i only have one book that
he wrote the reassess your chess book
and i have to admit that i got it but
never really looked at it so much didn't
find the time many people like his book
so it's probably probably pretty ok ok
so i hope you enjoyed this live stream
it's been a little bit longer than usual
one hour 15 minutes or so clerk and the
other ones are usually then known as
well hope you enjoyed it and i might be
streaming on tuesday as well so tuesday
the 29th not entirely sure I put out a
message and to see on my channel thanks
for watching guys